okay we're gonna talk all-stars for ya
it's getting down to the wire it's
getting gaggy on the show it is uncouth
yeah not good but good gotta okay who do
you want to win all stars for off the
top Trinity the Tuck
she's very diverse she is just a
fabulous drag queen she's come so far
since her season and she's a great
person she was actually a really good
friend to me on the show provided me
with the support that I kind of needed
from a friend not necessarily another
competitor in the competition and so for
me she's the winner in my eyes I'm gonna
tell you something you're harder than
the right place and no matter what you
need to know that you are deserving and
you are accepted not who you want but
who do you think um I think we're
probably looking at Monet exchange as
the winner yeah yeah I do and and that's
just what I think who I agree with okay
but that's who I am I am speculating
right now girls so what up I mean maybe
some of that sweat on that forehead give
me a couple words to describe Mona um
the thing is I don't really have words
for this scraper I also just don't know
her that well I could say that I guess
maybe she's funny she's she's
yeah moving on who don't you want to win
or I mean we don't want to say somebody
shouldn't win but in your opinion who
does not deserve money exchange yeah I'm
a little confused why she's still in the
competition and yeah I just I just don't
see her as a winner
I see somebody like a Trinity or Naomi I
would love for an Asian American to win
the show I'm still waiting for either an
Asian or Latina to win the show not that
race matters but at the other day you
know it's nice to be inclusive of
everybody but yeah I just don't really
like her looks and I think that she is
talented but I also think she has a lot
more polishing up to do and I think some
of the other growth have definitely
brought you know bra debt stronger than
she has